last night president putin flagrantly
violated the mink's peace agreements by
recognizing the supposed independence of
the so-called people's republics of
donetsk and luhansk in eastern ukraine
in a single inflammatory speech
he denied that ukraine had any tradition
of genuine statehood
claimed that it posed a direct threat
to the security of russia
and hurled numerous other false
accusations and aspersions
soon afterwards the kremlin announced
that russian troops would enter the
breakaway regions under the guise of
peacekeepers
and russian tanks and armored personnel
carriers have since been spotted the
house
should be in no doubt that the
deployment of these forces in sovereign
ukrainian territory amounts to a renewed
invasion of that country
and by denying ukraine's legitimacy as a
state
and presenting its very existence as a
mortal threat to russia putin is
establishing the pretext
for a full-scale offensive
i think honourable members will struggle
to understand
how in the or to contemplate how in the
year 2022
a national leader might calmly and
deliberately plot the destruction
of a peaceful neighbor
yet the evidence in his of his own words
suggests that is exactly what president
putin is doing
when i said on saturday that is scheme
to subvert and invade ukraine was
already in motion before our eyes
the events of the last 24 hours have
sadly shown this to be true
we must now brace ourselves for the next
possible stages of putin's plan
the violent subversion of areas of
eastern ukraine by russian operatives
and their harlings
followed by a general offensive by the
nearly 200 000 russian troops gathered
on the frontiers at peak readiness to
attack
if the worst happens
then a european nation of 44 million men
women and children would become the
target of a full-scale war
of aggression
waged
without a shred
of justification
for the absurd and even mystical reasons
that putin described last night
unless the situation changes the best
efforts of the united states of this
country france germany and other allies
to avoid conflict
through patient
diplomacy
may be in vain
from the beginning
we have tried our rightmost we've all
tried to find a peaceful way through
this crisis on the 11th of february my
right honourable friend the defense
secretary and the chief of the defense
staff admiral radekin
paid the first joint visit to moscow by
the holders of their offices since
churchill who was also defence minister
at the time traveled to russia with
general allen brooke in 1944.
they held over three hours of frank
discussions with the russian defense
minister general shoigu and the chief of
staff general garasimov
demonstrating how seriously we take
russia's security concerns how much
we respect her history
and how hard we are prepared to work
to ensure peaceful coexistence my right
honourable friend the foreign secretary
delivered the same messages when she met
our russian counterpart in moscow on the
10th
of february i've spoken on a number of
occasions to president putin since his
crisis began so does president biden
while president macron and chancellor
schultz have both visited moscow
together we have explored every avenue
and given putin every opportunity
to pursue his aims by negotiation and
diplomacy and i will tell the house we
will not give up
we will continue to seek a diplomatic
solution until the last possible moment
but we have to face
the possibility that none of our
messages has been heeded and that putin
is implacably determined
to go further
in subjugating and tormenting ukraine
and it is because we suspected as much
that the uk and our allies repeatedly
sounded the alarm about a possible new
invasion and we disclosed much of what
we knew about russia's military buildup
britain has done everything possible to
help ukraine to prepare for another
onslaught training 22 000 soldiers
supplying 2 000 anti-tank missiles and
providing 100 million pounds for
economic reform and energy independence
we will now guarantee up to 500 million
dollars of development bank financing
i traveled to kiev to meet president
zolensky on the 1st of february i saw
him again in
munich uh the weekend i spoke to him
again last night
soon after
president putin's speech
to assure him as i'm sure the whole
house uh would would uh would agree was
the right thing to do i assured him of
britain's unwavering support for
ukraine's
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
and now the uk and our allies will begin
begin to impose the sanctions on russia
that we have already prepared using the
new and unprecedented powers granted by
this house to sanction russian
individuals and entities of strategic
importance to the kremlin
today the uk is sanctioning the
following five russian banks
rossia is bank gen general bank
promising as bank and the black sea bank
and we are sanctioning three very high
net worth individuals gennady timchenko
boris rottenberg and igor rotenberg
any assets they hold in the uk
will be frozen the individuals concerned
will be banned from traveling here
and we will prohibit all uk individuals
and entities from having any dealings
with them
this is the first trash
the first barrage of what we are
prepared to do and we hold further
sanctions at readiness
to be deployed alongside the united
states and the european union if the
situation escalates still further
last night our diplomats joined an
emergency meeting of the un security
council and we will raise the situation
in the organization for security and
cooperation in europe
and
let me emphasize what i believe unites
every member of this house
with equal determination the resolve
of the united kingdom
to defend our nato allies is absolute
and immovable
we've already doubled the size of our
deployment in estonia where the british
army leads nato's battle group and when
i met president levitz of latvia and
prime minister kalas of estonia in
munich on saturday i told them that we
would be willing to send more british
forces to help protect our allies if
nato makes such a request
we cannot tell what will happen in
the days ahead but mr speaker we should
steal ourselves for a protracted crisis
the united kingdom will meet this
challenge side by side with our allies
determined that we will not allow putin
to drag our continent back into a
hobbesian state of nature where
aggression pays and might is right and
it is precisely because the stakes are
so high
that putin's venture
in ukraine
must fail
must ultimately fail and must be seen
to fail
that will require the perseverance
and the unity and the resolve of the
entire western alliance and
britain the uk will do everything
possible to ensure
that that unity is maintained
and now
our thoughts should turn
to our valiant ukrainian friends
who threaten no one
who ask for nothing
except to live in peace
and freedom
we will keep pace keep faith with them
in the critical days that lie ahead
and whatever happens mr speaker britain
will not waver in our resolve and i
commend this statement to the house
[Applause]